[Music]
in boolean power news
oh let's empower the bullies
submitted by handy-dandy handy-dandy
notebook
oh yeah my handy-dandy notebook
I don't know is it that's not my
generation you're gonna bring it back
this year though we're John Cena right
no no that'd be [ __ ] cool they need
to bring back bloodsport
we should we may get you guys to do it
I'm not good enough well who can do the
splits I know that's the Bravo
a man confronted his childhood bully at
a school board meeting I seen this and
it's great I know well how old is this
man sixties see oh wow
I remember three it was this Fresh
Prince episode where we'll finally had
the courage to [ __ ] confront his
bully because they heard he heard that
like his bully was back in town and all
this stuff when he was back in Philly
oh yeah well or something like that and
when he saw him so when you saw him this
bully was a preacher yeah oh oh that's
what I'm hearing this I hope that the
person he confronted is still the same
person that he was when he was a child
yeah so this is not as satisfying exact
and people also change it evolve over
time yeah and you don't know yeah hell
yeah [ __ ] his ass up yeah it was like
Brad my dad's gonna sue you he's been
holding resent like 40 years or some
[ __ ] he's 50 years old
35 [ __ ] Oh holding onto this for that
long I think I would too yes a long time
only it's a punchable ass face - yeah
I'll show you guys 50 cent you're having
trouble face I'd be a senior citizen if
I saw my [ __ ] bully and I'm 70 years
old
it's [ __ ] going on I'm like What's Up
[ __ ]
I'll do it I'll [ __ ] fight like an
old man - I'll just do one of these
things like [ __ ] your wrist
flexibility Irish fisticuffs [ __ ] your
ass up
girls burn when they have nails - it
actually still hurts it hurts a lot
yeah problems right alright so I'm gonna
show you guys a clip of when the
confrontation happened yeah I love this
man like Bravo to this man you had me
eat my own day hey I know it's pretty
sad I wanted to see some light you
torment to me [ __ ] and then he
goes over and he passes him and he
pulled his underwear all-time wears like
this and in the underwears on atomic
that's the atomic wedgie like he does it
back to him yeah you try to do that to
Charlie Day and always sending in
Philadelphia but is unaware of Seoul
they just tore I like that show cuz of
you stupid yeah you know what people are
bullies people are bullies because they
got molested oh my god they're always so
spoiled as [ __ ] yeah there's a lot of
reasons Joe so a more spoiled little
piece I mean that's one of the reasons
or like they got they got like just to
let you enjoy Sergeant John want to
watch this movie it's a movie yeah okay
good okay here we go
my name is Greg Barrett I graduated from
KST in 1983 I started in 1975 with mr.
Lantz my legal brings in Gregor gay oh
because of your last name unbelievably
bullied I started out and I had teachers
that bully me all mad kids because your
name's day coaches I had nobody to turn
to it doesn't make it okay one day at
lunch I had my [ __ ] head shoved in the
urinal
that's not right that is not that's
[ __ ] on the ground in a fetal position
as the kids kicked me not a cola rinsed
my face off I walked out of the
lunchroom walk straight to the
principal's office and he told me
kids will grow up someday they won't
always be like this
but yet Here I am
covered in urine from laying on the
ground underneath the urinal my limp was
busted and they sent me home when I went
home and I got the 45 out of my father's
drawer and put it in my mouth oh no
nobody in the school system to help me
is is is that the way this is going to
be Lance you the one that shoved my head
in the urinal oh [ __ ]
thank you
[Music]
why would he debate that how do you
debate this his laugh is the thing that
blows he just laughed at him and what
witnesses your [ __ ] friends I didn't
see that's pretty severe because it's
like look at his face
oh he looks like you want to upper cut
his [ __ ] jaw off his mouth he has
that [ __ ] mouth you just want to
punch the more I said sometimes people
just have faces that you just want to
slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] he looks like a
good punching yeah I will say all
American wholesome man you know what
sucks though I will say this I just had
a conversation back in the day so me and
my my best friend we actually had this
moment where when you're a kid and you
get bullied there's a moment that I
think a lot of these kids who do get
bullied they try to bully somebody else
yeah so I think that's what happens yes
when I was a kid I remember this very
specific moment I just had this
conversation with him so there's this
kid named name with run deep Sidhu he
was like this Indian kid right so I had
nothing against it but I was bullied a
lot as a kid too I wanted to know what
it felt like to bully somebody so I
remember one time they put like this
kick me sign on it and everybody's like
kicking the show and I won't lie I feel
kicking myself but when I did I remember
I went after I was like yo I didn't feel
good I felt terrible and so from then I
never bullied anybody else after that so
this was like when I was like seven year
old years old I believe but it's kind of
weird like how
you don't know what that feels like
until let's say you get bullied and you
try to do it somebody else yeah it does
sometimes it feels terrible and he does
the he same situation happen to my best
friend where he actually made fun of
that same kid in class and then
afterwards he felt terrible about he
apologized on that so it kind of sucks
dude
you don't know what happens out there it
turns out that that kid though we don't
know his kids but that kid actually has
he had a developmental disorder so oh no
as kids you don't really know that and
that kid is a [ __ ] disabled truck you
know I was I was seven years old at the
time and nobody knew I only knew that
kid had a developmental disorder when I
met him in high school and so I saw him
a high school he still remember me
because after that moment I didn't bully
him anymore and I stuck up for the kid
because I felt so bad and he also shared
findings with me although oxy was the
thing that you know I was like I was his
friend and he was share funny looking
stuff for Liam I don't know what
happened to him after because I got
kicked out of school so I guess so sad
dude because like I remember people made
fun of each other all day named Colin
but I think the ones that didn't fight
back or say anything back they were even
more like hazed by everyone because they
didn't do anything back and then like
this is pretty extreme though because I
don't remember any kids being like
thrown into urine all these things for
having a name it was never me it was
because they had a smart mouth or they
were just socially weird because or like
they were offensive to other people and
then it's like okay that's why he got
you know jumped it's because he's
mouthing off he's talking [ __ ] he was
spreading rumors or something was
happening like that I don't think it's
justified but I saw like a cause and
effect I've never seen a case where was
like oh this guy has a funny name so
let's be violent toward him I was like
that's [ __ ] up yeah it's a little odd
cuz even like a dad like that kid got
picked on a lot because the way he
dressed so he she wore overalls like
bright green yellows he were a bowtie to
saying punk him a lot too and so like he
and I ended up being like good to each
other just because like I felt so
terrible after that I would always like
stick up for him but the problem with
that is when you stick up for a kid that
gets bullied you also get bullied too
but I was a big kid so it didn't [ __ ]
matter like you could swing on me but
I'm like twice your size and at that
time we mail him into school when you're
twice the size everybody else it size
does matter
yeah it wasn't so bad for me because if
somebody just pushed me I just you know
I would kick them that's why I got
expelled for this what what was his
point of talking about bullies in the
school and doing all well they were
there for like a public meeting that was
a school district that's a [ __ ]
superintendent now yeah well I mean like
I could see how he went into that line
of work he's a [ __ ] loser so okay you
don't make a lot of money he's a [ __ ]
and he's rich Oh rich [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] he's in charge of the entire
school district immediately he was
denying it and he even came out with a
statement saying like you know as a
superintendent in three school districts
in Texas I have always tried to create
an environment where every student is
safe physically and emotionally but when
an individual in comes my character and
reputation as the instigator of those
actions I'm disappointed because it
simply is not true but there is this
other man named crystalline who came
forward saying I walked in on that I saw
that this dude Lance was the head bully
like he was the one I mean I don't even
see the motive no moat I this man would
go in there hmm
and have to say that and call out let's
see all the emotions it's like and then
he remember [ __ ] like that you do not
make it up and say oh actually it was
so-and-so but for some reason I
accidentally remembered it was someone
else and it's just like you can clearly
see the type of piece of [ __ ] at least
Lance dude is like he didn't learn
anything he's still the same person
because the immediate reaction was to
laugh it off and then accepted he's like
it's unbelievable and what would he even
look better if you would have been like
you know what yeah we were all kids I'm
so sorry I don't remember that I'm sorry
you know we were kids I was a freakin
brat or whatever but now I know better I
do let's go grab lunch like he would
have been a [ __ ] angel yeah then
that's all that Gary says it's like all
wanted was for him to apologize and like
that's it thank you and he must have
been bullied so much we had to change
his name he did he do to that he went
through a lot that's not it the
superintendent guy probably bullied so
much people that he would even remember
that yeah yeah that's um but I also know
nobody else with the last name gay but
he's actually a six-foot I don't know
him personally but he's like a six foot
nine basketball player so different
story
yeah one of the fastest runners for
America's last name is gay - that's so
mean
the part when he says oh do you want to
beat that cuz I have witnesses yeah the
other bullies know that was from Gary
Gary said that Oh Gary said that oh not
the superintendent Oh what's good then
yeah and Gary said well I thought the
superintendent's a was he want to debate
that I have witnesses no because uh you
sound like it's unbelievable he's just
kind of like Oh cuz it was in so the
subtitles on top was Gary yeah all the
red was a superintendent the way he
laughed afterwards i dude like if he
wasn't Jamal you what would you do she
wouldn't even be superintendent not
necessarily what could be a Super
Nintendo I would make him go through I
would make him go through like the rest
of his life I would build a fake school
and they do bully him oh I like that
Oh like the rest of his life shove them
into urinals kick him shoving to things
pretty cool right especially like I mean
I do believe that people can't change
and yeah we should be nicer but he
didn't repent yeah because of that he
gets all of his fingers smashed I never
understood boiling like you know what
like to kick me signs when I saw kids
with them always just took it off of him
you know what it is it's like Bob
mentality so it's like for me like I
remember that moment cuz a little
scarring for me cuz I'm so disappointed
in myself
yeah like because when you get bullied
and you start doing the same thing you
know get yourself right as a kid you
have a conscience so it's like well what
the [ __ ] am I do I think it's it's
really like a hierarchy power thing
whether it's within females or guys
there's always like a structure of whose
bottom whose top and people are always
competing for that right so if someone's
you know making you feel like below you
want to make someone else feel below so
you don't feel so low in the totem pole
right and I specifically remember I had
a really fun time in third and fourth
grade specifically trying to fight with
guys bigger than me
and then I it made me feel powerful if I
can pick on them and win and I looked
for guys that were bigoted so I could go
around and back like yeah that guy like
I punched him he didn't do anything he's
bigger than me too so I think it's um
it's it's really one of those
power-hungry things it's an insecurity
for sure
I did that but I don't consider that
bully because they're better than me I
know but it is bully if a guy is like
now you know like I guess I bullied I
mean that's the justification it's like
I'm I'm a pick on this guy cuz he's
bigger than yeah he's a bigger you know
but you don't know you might be a real
soft person yeah
[Music]
[Music]